[Música]
2.288 terquedad con propósito
ese número es el resultado de esta
fórmula y ahorita ni es el número ni
esta fórmula significa nada pero créanme
que después de esta charla todo tendrá
sentido
nuestra generación aunque es rica en
retos y relaciones parece no conocer el
significado de la palabra perseverancia
perseverancia es esa terquedad pero con
un propósito sí
estamos muy acostumbrados a que nos
digan que tenemos que luchar en la vida
sin nombre es joseph para el día de hoy
vengo a decirte que dejes de esforzar
porque yo que un perdedor muchos años
el esfuerzo siempre te lleva a una lucha
yo cuando luche piensen ustedes a que te
llevan a una lucha yo cuando luche me
debilite me lastimé bella mis rivales
como mis enemigos estaba deprimido
estaba enojado con la vida
en cambio el esmero siempre lleva una
libertad la única diferencia es que el
esmero es el amor aplicado a lo que hace
la perseverancia es la parte sabia del
éxito y qué significa esto me podrían
decir yo sé porque quiero perseverar
para qué sirve eso qué
como nos podemos explicar cuando otros
logran cosas increíbles o que parecen
imposibles como cuando inventaron la
primera máquina voladora no unos
granjeros que no tenían ni presupuesto
que los criticaban que hasta el 'new
york times' post yo estaban locos bueno
o estos artistas que yo la veo y se me
acelera el corazón porque es una mujer
que vive con una pasión increíble sino
la conocencia madre tan hija newton y
cuando era un adolescente sufrió un
ataque de tiburón literalmente le
arrancó el brazo
y después de un tiempo se rehabilitó
venció su miedo y se convirtió en
campeona mundial de eso como lo hizo no
tengo ni idea porque empezó a remar con
un brazo hoy o si está muy difícil tuve
que hacer muchas cosas pero lo logró
a estos fenómenos que el día de hoy son
una leyenda pero no sé si sabían que los
virus en los años de celle nadie los
conocía para que ha mentido yo creo que
john lennon llegaba con su mamá y de
mamá voy a tener una presentación
no no es broma o sea es que se ríen pero
los virus tuvieron que irse de londres
hamburgo porque no tenían alarmas y no
tienen chamba en donde empezaron a tocar
en un bar pero ro por dos años y tocaban
ocho horas al día los siete días de la
semana entonces cómo podemos explicar no
que personas así hayan logrado estas
cosas alguien que lo explica de forma
increíble es malcolm gladwell tiene un
libro que se llama out layers y está
increíble malcom dice que tú necesitas
10.000 horas de entrenamiento de
práctica de hacer algo para lograr una
maestría o ser un experto en algún tema
y adivinen qué
yo soy aquí ando vals es un resultado de
esta teoría yo soy el vivo ejemplo de
que esta feria es real
se acuerdan al principio que les dije
que era un fracasado pues yo durante
muchísimo tiempo fiel peor judoca de
méxico judo es mi deporte y por muchos
años la gente se reía donde iba conmigo
y por qué se reían porque era renal o se
hiciera muy malo entonces imagínense que
yo voy a luchar voy a convertir y me
toca con el enfermito pues dices bueno
no voy a gane pasaron cuatro años y en
esos cuatro años yo no gané ni un solo
combate
entonces yo cuando ya estaba a punto de
quiebre no triste llega un entrenador y
me cuestionó al el primero que que me
hizo entrar en razón amigo cuantas horas
entrenas y cuántas horas se entrena la
gente que te gana
entonces ahí fue como si el espíritu
santo me hablara de creo pues si yo
estaba entrenando tres horas al día
cuando la gente que me ganaba y era
superior
estaba entrenando más de 62 yo pase en
ese en ese momento de entrenar tres
horas al día a entrenar siete horas
diarias y me di cuenta fue como una
película una retrospectiva y cuando lo
que sea cuando logré ser campeón
nacional y cuando empecé a representar a
méxico a nivel mundial sume el número de
horas que llevaba llevaba 12 mil 288
horas
un número que tal vez para ustedes no
signifique mucho no 10.000 logras más
lograr algo con unos amigos entonces
quiero que hagan un ejercicio conmigo
imagínense que le vamos a dedicar sólo
dos horas al día a lo que nos apasiona
lo que nos encanta
si hacemos esto vamos a llegar a esas
10.000 horas en 14 años
si vamos a duplicar lo vamos a trabajar
cuatro horas al día la mitad no siete
años pero qué pasa cuando sólo le
dedicamos 30 minutos de nuestro día
hacer a la concertación
saben cuántos agsal
alguien son más de 52 años entonces si
te estás cuestionando hay porque a veces
no logro lo que quiero
entonces porque necesitas ponerla
entonces
bueno alrededor de hace como tres años
yo estaba deprimido y en terapia en
terapia psicológica y su descubrimiento
y este descubrimiento
se llama pan
yo ahí me di cuenta
pero me di cuenta que no me estaba
esforzando lo suficiente sí y que
significaban porque la de plata se me
hace perro en el nombre dan dan es
voluntad acción imagen y vamos con el
primero
voluntad la voluntad es el ejercicio del
poder interior si es con esas ganas de
hacer
pero pues algo tan sencillo pero algo
que ignoramos muchísimo
sí porque al tener fuerza de voluntad
medio caracas
pero es el resultado de una libre
elección quítense de la cabeza que
tienen que estar luchando que tienen que
estar peleando pero ojo eso no quiere
decir que no tengan
simplemente acuérdense que esfuerzo y
esmero es la misma cosa
vamos con la segunda todos con acción
quieren saber lo que es acción para ti
muévete literal es súper fácil pero lo
tienes que hacer todos los días y es
para mover que hacen falta pantalones
hace falta pantalones para que entiendas
y sepas que todas tus acciones van a
tener consecuencias y agarrate porque si
no haces nada todas eso todo surge se
genera toda esa energía va a venir en
contra de ti
el mundo sigue girando a nosotros nos
guste o no nunca se va a detener
pero en acción es entender que siempre
está sucediendo algo si estás dormido si
está rascando las nalgas está sucediendo
algo si estás corriendo estás trabajando
está sucediendo al cuando te digan
acción lo que tienes que hacer es
ponerle un significado y un objetivo a
lo que estás haciendo porque trabajo
el trabajar sin un objetivo no tiene
sentido estás cansando estás trabajando
en vano mi mamá me dijo esto años y yo
no le hacía caso era muy interactivo
giuseppe piensa antes de actuar
a mi madre ahorita lo entiendo
ahorita viene mi favorita
cuando tú agarras la voluntad y tienes
esta fuerza de voluntad y tienes esta
energía y decides porque es una decisión
tomar acción y empiezas a crear todo
esto
viene aquí algo que se llama magia y la
magia para mí es no no son estos trucos
baratos sino es la magia como la que
conocemos si para mí la magia no es no
es hacer una lista y pedir deseos y
decirle adiós que te cumpla milagros la
magia está es que dios pone un poder
dentro de ninguna parte de él dentro de
ti
todos tenemos ese poder diminuto
pero tú eres el que logra y crear las
cosas tú eres el que decide ir por tu
sueño es el que literal decide poner
acción
y super bonito porque nosotros somos
mares y si un día empiezas a crear y
decides humana acción
vas a despertar un día vas a empezar a
mirar a tu alrededor y vas a ver que
todo todo es magia y esta magia está
siendo creada entonces algo padrísimo
entonces para para ponerla así más o
menos para que me la vayan entendiendo
voluntad más acción es igual la magia
pero no sé si les ha pasado que cuando
están comiendo y piden un postrecito y
le dan una mordida al varón le dicen
no le falta pues a mí esta fórmula así
como tal aunque esté ahorita incompleta
me cambió la vida pero siempre sentía
que le hacía falta algo estaba
incompleta y hace un año aprox un
poquito más de un año encontré el último
ingrediente
y literalmente todo tuvo sentido es la
perseverancia
en términos matemáticos de las de aller
de masa es igual a m todo multiplicado o
todo elevado a la máxima perseverancia
la perseverancia cissé energía es esa
magia es esa decisión que mantiene todos
juntos si ahora quiero que hagamos un
ejercicio sí que haber quien quiera ser
un ejercicio levante la mano por favor y
si se animan quiero que saquen su
celular ahorita y quiero que lo
mantengan aquí si ahorita ya se me van a
cansar pero no quiero que lo bajen
estamos de acuerdo
es como la perseverancia como yo lo veo
es como si estamos en una escuela cuanto
si queremos ir a eeuu
yo me puedo ir en jet privado e irme así
yo puedo irme caminando o me puedo ir
haciendo
puedo pedirle al link que me cargue ya
sé que ya había algunos que lo están
bajando en no sé me bajen a ver ok
entonces del punto a al punto b si es
nuestra meta hay muchos caminos
y tener muchos caminos no está mal
porque la decisión es tuya pero cuando
nos cuestionamos
el cuestión el cuestionarse es una tapa
al éxito ya sé que se están cansando ya
mero acabamos esperen un poquito
cuando nos estamos cuestionando
literalmente siempre confiesen porque
cuando dicen oye para qué haces esto
contestamos el por qué no él para que el
cuestionarse es poderosísimo si ya uno
ya los van bajando pero aguanté me falta
poquito
literalmente solo quiero que se hagan
esta pregunta
si te cuestionas las cosas que haces
ahora sí por favor quiero que se pongan
de pie un segundo la gente que sí
mantuvo y sean brutalmente honestos el
celular así hasta el final
porque les quiero dar un aplauso
felicidades y les voy a decir la neta ya
se pueden sentar ustedes tienen lo que
se necesita para perseverar porque la
perseverancia bueno para mí es sostener
lo que dijiste
sí ahora sí bajaron al brazo no se me
vayan a gritar está bien acuérdense que
es un ejercicio es una práctica que se
hace todos los días pero bien sostener
lo que dije hasta el final la
importancia de que nuestras palabras
tienen poder y tenemos comprar nuestra
palabra
y a ver se acuerda que le dije que la
perseverancia era la savia del éxito no
me crean a mí quiero que vean los
ejemplos quiero que ustedes sabían que
la mamá de albert einstein llegaron
ligero oye toma tu hijito está tonto
porque albert en sí no podía ni leer
porque era de su éxito a un hitler no un
cabrón que puso al mundo en jaque lo
corrieron de su escuela si fue vagabundo
unos años
pero fue un personaje que pudo manipular
a todo un país ya toda una nación
diciendo que eran los elegidos pero ojo
él lo hizo sin honor porque en la
perseverancia también nos podemos perder
si nos podemos ahogar en nuestros
pensamientos en nuestro ego sí y aquí
le vamos a agregar el último ingrediente
a esta fórmula es el ingrediente que
literalmente es esa bola de nieve que le
faltaba algo
para no darte
en juego
tus pensamientos pero aunque lo
diga así
no lo puedes hacer si necesitas entender
qué necesitas un equipo para cuando te
estés jugando y cuando estés perdido
alguien que te diga que te haga ver el
contraste de lo que está pasando y que
te agarre de las grillas y te diga nada
más para que ya vas mal yo lo hice con
un terapeuta con mi familia con un amigo
pero ustedes tienen un trabajo aquí o
como yo le digo a su manada
y ahora si la fórmula está completa
voluntad más activamente pitan conmigo
voluntad más acciones igualan y todo
elevado a la máxima
y todo lo mantiene juntos
la manada muy bien
atención ahora a que una parte súper
importante de la voluntad a la acción
hay un puente y voy a poner el mismo
ejemplo de cuatro cuerpos eeuu quedó el
primero que cuando ustedes llegan a una
frontera de eeuu que lo primero que te
vas a topar administró smith con zinc
guardián normal whatsapp no
en la voluntad de la acción pasa lo
mismo hay un guardia que no nos permite
tomar
que no nos permiten entrar a eeuu es el
ego el ego es el enemigo porque no es el
ego es malo es el es el gran adversario
de la perseverancia y no manejar mentir
a quién le ha pasado que mañana y ya voy
a empezar a entrenar no voy a poner las
pilas
a comer bien pero fíjate que antes de
dormir prendo la tele y está luis miguel
la serie noventas
en capítulo dos capítulos tres capítulos
y attorneys de las tres de la mañana y
al día siguiente cuando te pita tu
alarma
a todos nos ha pasado los leoneses nos y
a la tercera que le explicas y nos dice
es mejor año
está cañón y lo que tienes que aprender
es que cuando empiezas a decidir y
cuando le des piel a tu palabra y logras
vencer a ese ojo cada vez se va haciendo
más
pero es muy importante que este año
puedo yo seguir hablando horas
literalmente horas y dándoles muchos
ejemplos pero me gustaría que se
encontra en sillas principales número la
perseverancia es la terquedad con
propósito es serle fiel
los pies en las últimas
cuando dices que vas a económicas que
vas a hacer hazlo normas que no se
queden en palabras sino tu propio poder
se va a dedicar
número 2 cuando ya tengas ese propósito
para que ese propósito esté claro y
tenga sentido
tienes que reflexionar y cuestionar para
que lo estás haciendo
y necesitás ahí a un amigo para que te
ayude literalmente a sacarte las greñas
cuando te estás ahogando dele
esto se llama uno más uno es igual a
tres si esto - en un mentor al cual
quiero muchísimo que dice cuando tú
tienes a un amigo a un equipo y está
luchando por algo en común gran sinergia
el resultado nuestros estrés mismas
entonces empiecen a entrar y número tres
te vas a dar cuenta de que tú que este
propósito que alguien que vas por buen
camino cuando tú empiezas a crecer y
empiezas a hacer crecer a tu gente que
esté a tu alrededor y súper bueno
y aquí quiero que todos cierran sus ojos
por favor vamos a terminar por favor
cierra sus ojos quiero que respiren una
vez pero que inhalen
examen quiero que lo vuelvan a hacer
examen y quiero que me ayuden a leer
esto en voz alta por favor
cuando fue la última vez que trabajaste
para lograr tus sueños
mi nombre es josé farah y yo sé si lo
que escuchaste ahorita te gustó o no te
gustó el estudio de algo pero yo lo hice
muchas gracias